Oh, you still got it.
Great serve.
Thank you.
A while ago we did a
video called Jello Tennis,
I think was the name.
Jelly Tennis?
Jelly Tennis, probably Jelly Tennis,
because we're from England.
Yeah.
And we did it about 2,500 FPS, since then,
technology has advanced.
We can now do 12,000
frames a second in full HD
with the v2640.
Also, jelly technology has improved.
We've managed to do
multicolored rainbow jelly. Ooh.
Now this technology did exist
back when we did it the first time.
We just couldn't be bothered.
And I'm glad we didn't do it last time,
'cause that took forever.
It took me a week to do like 20 of these.
Cause you have to set individual layers.
Each layer takes about eight hours to set.
Yeah.
So we made a load of them
because probably we're not going
to get it every single time.
It's really difficult
to get the framing right
with the tennis and the
jelly and everything.
I think that's literally
the same tennis racket
that we used last time.
It's still sticky from last time.
All right, let's get this
table out of the way.
Let's frame up the Phantom,
and get some lovely shots,
some jelly getting cut
up into little strips.
I'm going to get that jelly out nicely.
We'll give that to you.
This is the Phantom v2640.
It's a liquid-cooled beast that does
12 and a half thousand
frames a second in full HD.
Okay. First attempt.
Good luck.
Ready?
Yeah.
Oh, dammit.
sake.
Wish me luck this time.
Go for it.
I hit it.
Yeah.
This is a good speed. I like the speed.
That's pretty sweet. Chunky jelly, though.
Oh yeah.
Absolutely diced.
Oh, that was perfect.
Look at those colors there. It's wicked.
That's so cool.
I like that.
That's awesome. All those little worms.
So I need to be lower.
Okay.
I think, looking up?
Alright.
Cause you're hitting it
a lot lower than we've--
Yeah, it's cause, I think
last time, I had it in my hand
and I was lobbing it, which
meant I had more time,
but because the jelly is so big now,
Yeah.
And like more, it matters more
about the individual colors
and the colors are so thin,
I'm just having to drop it
out of this, which means
I'm having to come up
from lower down than I was before.
All right.
It's not end of the world.
So we've got light there
to backlight the jelly,
just so it's a little
glowy when Dan hits it,
and a pretty shoddy white background
just so we're not shooting
against the fence.
You ready, Daniel?
Yeah. My jelly keeps farting, though.
Really?
Yeah. It's like, it keeps just guffing.
Oh, I like splashed it in the rim.
You can see the rim of
the tennis racket move.
Oh, I left behind some
of the colors there.
Dammit.
Go for it.
You've annihilated the background.
Oh no! What are we going to do?
I love how it goes from
just being a sort of
questionable-looking blob.
It looks like an amoeba.
Yeah. It's like you're
hitting a rainbow egg
that just erupts into absolute beaut-
Look at that!
And suddenly, a rainbow was born.
Wow. - [Gavin] That's pretty cool.
That's sweet.
That's bloody cool.
You can see every individual color.
It looks like, it literally
looks like a rainbow
has been formed out of
giant wormy rain droplets.
It looks like a unicorn sneezed.
I would hate to be on
the bottom end of that.
You can see all the stuff
sailing towards the back
like
You absolutely munched it.
Oh, I'm sorry.
Should I hose it down or something?
Nah, it's only,
it's like a, it's just so
we're not looking at the fence.
It doesn't have to be too clean.
I'll go for the slightly trickiest shot.
Changing our focal length
to, like sort of that,
which drastically shrinks the window.
That makes both of our jobs much harder.
Yes.
'Cause I've been struggling
to hit it properly
with the wide.
Yeah.
Now if the rest of these
jellies are pretty much going
to be used to try and get
it so that, pardon me,
I can get it right in frame, on the tight.
Missed half of it.
All right, you got this.
Come on.
Oh, shut the
So hard.
Oh, dammit!
All right. Let's check this one out.
Take 48.
Have a bit of a floppage
coming down there.
Yeah, alright.
Some of the jelly's a bit--
Splittage. - [Daniel] Yeah.
Oh, it's just in the racket.
That is some multicolored wormage.
Wow.
It's so difficult because not only,
it's like half of it's down to chance.
Yeah.
Because the jelly has to be
spinning at the right place
to get the colors in the right area.
And I have to hit it exactly
in the middle of the racket,
exactly the right time.
All right now, while
Dan gets another Jello,
I flipped the entire set up 180
because the sun is now low enough
where it's perfectly
backlighting these jellies
and Dan is definitely
going to get on this one.
Aren't you, Dan?
Oh yeah. Yeah, we are.
Yeah, okay, here we go.
I think it was good. I think it was good.
I think you misted it.
I think I did.
The sun is so low now,
that's we're literally wedged
into the very back corner,
'cause it's like 5:00 PM now.
Alright.
Let's take a look at it.
So the background's a lot darker because,
Yeah.
You're going against,
It's hard to see what's
even going on here.
Shove your face right in. Yeah.
See now?
Oh yeah!
There's a bit of orange Jello coming down.
Here it comes, here it comes.
Look at the glisten through that.
Oh, that's deluxe. That's
absolutely luscious.
Here we come, come on, nail it.
Oh, yeah! Oh, yeah.
Look at that.
That's well cool. That's wicked.
I love it.
It was perfectly like each jel--
each little eel had every color in it.
Each eel. Each rainbow eel.
Very nice work. And a lot of
them, a lot of the lower ones,
they all go from being
long worms to curling
the exact same way.
It's really weird, isn't
it? How does that happen?
All I'm doing is hitting it with a racket.
See, it was nice the last time you did it,
but now it's like fascinatingly nice,
'cause you can see
exactly what's going on.
I love the backlight. I think
that's the best decision.
How many more have we got?
That was the last normal one.
Okay. I feel like we
got it on the last one.
I'm not even sure we can show that.
Even though that was
incredibly time consuming
and frustrating to shoot, I
feel like we got the cream
that we wanted.
Honestly. I think the backlit
shot was worth it alone.
Yeah.
That was just so
cool-looking, the way, ah,
it looked sweet with the jelly
see-through and everything.
Yeah. It was just one of
those shots you look at
and you just think, oh, that's nice.
I like, I like looking at this. Did good.
Come to think of it,
that video has taken
us or me about 15 hours
of jelly making, hitting things.
I've got like a bad back now.
I'm like, I just been stood there today.
Just going, oh, God.
And now you need to sit down.
I need to sit down.
Oh, well hopefully you enjoyed
that lovely little revisit,
much slower revisit.
Feel free to follow us on
Instagram and all that.
We got a second channel
and we'll put another
video pretty damn soon.
Thanks for watching.